this is what I've got from the point
that I considered right now just pause
and think about this this is really good
news right because you can see not only
did I get a perfect square over here on
the right hand side here I actually got
exactly the perfect square that I was
after if you go all the way back to my
required to prove there it is right
there it's the X part of the circle
equation that's being squared there so
this is great right all I did was I
worked on this X part here so if I call
this equation one if I substitute this
result
substitute let's call this two
substitute 2 into 1
what have I got here well the left hand
side
this these X Parts here these X Parts
here which I didn't need to go up it's
just this part here right it turns into
this so I can just write all of that out
I can go X take away X1 plus x two onto
all squared on the right hand side of
the equation I'll leave a bit of space
here I'm going to end up with this
but then remember everything that we did
for X we can do for y as well because
it's exactly the same thing here it's
just repeated over there with y's
instead of x's so everything that I just
wrote I can say it again for y minus y1
plus Y 2 all over 2 squared so I've got
the equivalent part on the left I also
need the equivalent part on the right so
it's just going to have y's instead of
x's so
there you go
all right this is fantastic right
because you can see the left hand side
is already there I'm finished right oh
at least on the left hand side I don't
need to do any more manipulation on that
I can just focus on this right hand side
over here somehow I've got to get to the
fact that this is whatever I want
half of a b squared half of a b squared
now this is promising for two reasons
number one
the square I can see like I've got I've
got squared stuff over here right that's
positive in addition to that I also have
like what is
um there's there's a half here right and
a half that's being squared well there's
halves being squared down here and then
I've got a B well what is a b a b is
here right and you can see because I've
labeled them as just X1 y1 X2 Y2 that
entire length a b uh let's let's just
sort of drop it in here I can just get
using the distance formula which is just
Pythagoras right it's the square root of
X1 minus X2 squared plus y1 minus Y2
squared because a b is just the
hypotenuse of a triangle where one of
its sides is X1 minus X2 and the other
side is y1 minus Y2 and then you square
it because that's how Pythagoras works
now have a look at that X1 minus x2 in
fact I might even just copy this just so
you can see it alongside the working
that I'm currently doing
have a look here let's just change that
to something else so we don't get
distracted there we go so have a look at
how similar these things are right I've
got my X1 minus X2 squared right here up
in the numerator I've got my y1 minus Y2
squared up on the numerator so I'm
actually so very close I just need to do
a little bit of tweaking and I'll be
there all right so let's have a go
the first thing is um I wanna you can
see on here like the distance formula
doesn't have that uh these these
fractions in it because that comes from
me saying half the diameter I don't know
it's a diameter yet but half that length
and then that gets squared which creates
these uh twos down the bottom here right
so because I just want the distance
formula let's get those half squared out
of the way
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
just on the numerator here X1 minus x 2
squared plus y1 minus Y2 squared and
then that is all divided
by 2 squared okay so we'll come back to
that 2 squared in a moment
okay now you can see on the numerator
here this is pretty much identical to
what I have underneath the square root
here this is X1 minus X2 all squared
it's not pretty much identical it is
identical to what you have underneath
the square root over here so you've got
to be careful right how do I introduce a
square root well you can introduce a
square root if you introduce a square as
well because you don't actually want to
change what's on the numerator there
right but you can't just take the square
root of something and then Square it and
expect you always get the same thing for
example if you have a number like uh if
you haven't had a number like negative
five and then you square it and then
take the square root okay you don't end
up with the number that you started with
you end up with the Positive version
okay but if you uh have something that
you know is positive if you if you know
that you start with a positive number
I'll square it then take the square root
or you could do it in reverse order as
well you know you're going to end up
with five because you're just staying in
the realm of positive numbers so what
I'm going to do here is I'm going to
look and I'll say hey look at this
numerator right because we're dealing
just with the real numbers we're on the
Cartesian plane not the complex plane
none of these things are going to be
imaginary so when you take the
difference and then you square it you're
going to get something positive when you
take the difference and then you square
it you're going to get something
positive so therefore I can say that
everything here is going to be positive
so I can do this square square rooting
move that I I wanted to do before so let
me write that that logic because it's
quite important right
um so I can say
um but uh X1 minus x 2 squared plus y1
minus Y2 squared that's going to be
greater than or equal to zero so
therefore I can say let's take that
whole thing
all of it
don't need this orange highlighting
anymore and I can pop the square root
over the well that's really badly drawn
let's do that again there's a square
root draw that line over the top and
then Square it right so I can only do
this move because I know that there's
all of this going on here right and
there's no complex numbers or anything
like that so just be wary of that you
can't just take the square root and
square
um without being careful with your logic
Okay so
have a look now what have I got I've got
the numerator is squared the denominator
is squared so therefore I'm just going
to ball that fraction all into one I've
got the square root of
X1 minus x 2 squared plus y1 minus y 2
squared all of that is underneath the
square root
and then uh I also have
that 2 on the denominator I'm going to
write that as a fractional coefficient
and all of that all of that is squared
but then I can say hey hey this thing
here this is a b everything underneath
that square root so I can say this is
equal to half a b
all squared I left that left hand side
behind because I had already finished
with it
there we go I'm done as required
which despite the fact that it took much
longer than the first proof is sort of
satisfying in its own way right because
we didn't have to assume very much about
the situation we didn't even have a
circle there so we didn't use the circle
properties like radii and stuff like
that like we did with the plane geometry
proof the less you assume the more work
you have to do and we actually did have
to employ a lot of foundational
Knowledge from corner geometry like what
happens with um the products of
gradients of perpendicular lines and
then all this algebraic knowledge and
all that kind of thing so you can see it
ends up being quite lengthy but we
arrive at this same conclusion and we've
got the locus of P moving through this
imaginary Circle that we had before
so in conclusion coming all the way back
to this original problem uh I think it
was Carl Friedrich gas to the German
mathematician who said that mathematics
is comprised of thinking deeply about
simple things and there are a few things
as simple as a circle but there are all
of these wonderful detailed intricate
properties that they have some of which
you can prove easily and then you want
to think about you know doing the
converse of that and getting your logic
watertight
and that's what today was about so I
hope you found that interesting that
you're able to pursue the the deductive
reasoning that you're doing throughout
the course whether it's geometric or
otherwise and be really careful about
how you know things are true and why and
um Relish in the fact that you can prove
them and once they're proven in
mathematics they're proven forever